so her youngest is May and you you just
tried to cut her bangs right are you I
don't know so so you I guess I shouldn't
say tried you yeah do you succeed
exactly I was like my son literally last
night asked if I would cut his hair and
I was like hard pass bring him over to
my house you don't want me to cut your
hair like so you're comfortable with
that I'm like I feel like I'd make my
kid look like ridiculous and yours look
so cute so you even did like a little
shorter here I did
so someone taught me that you like make
try you like basically split them in
half and then just do like a triangle
and that's like that helped like a like
that over the face and I did it I just
put on freaking cocoa melon which like
is the savior to everything yeah or like
it makes them quiet and I cut them and
then my husband cut me off a couple
weeks later because he was like one cut
one trim per week I'm seeing you do this
every day but like it's weird because
I'll be like oh I left a little yeah and
then I'll just like give her a popsicle
and then just like get after it and he's
like she's gonna be like a rockabilly
chick in no time here like can you call
me which is cute yeah and now I found
this thing on Instagram of course
they're all listening to us I got ad
targeted have you seen this little
Shield that sticks to their face and
it's like clear so you don't run the
risk of like
I will never cut my children's hair okay
because see somebody could tell me oh
it's about triangles and then yeah
you're like she's had circles she said
no no I will attempt triangle and do
feel like I'm doing exactly what you're
doing and fail miserably and then my kid
will get made fun of at school my
ex-husband actually did that with my my
son he was like I tried to cut his hair
he gave him a buzz cut it was so short
and he was so upset about it that's what
that I'm him yeah and I got that I can't
do it I think that's amazing that you
can and also it's just annoying on your
schedule yeah my special talents list on
my resume just got bigger guys okay
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]